the government is working through our
action plan and at its core the
objective is to protect life and to
protect the NHS both by slowing the
spread of the virus so that we flatten
the curve and by ensuring that the NHS
always has more than enough capacity to
provide critical care for all those who
needed according to the most recent
figures there have been seven hundred
and nineteen thousand nine hundred and
ten tests for coronavirus so far in the
UK including 37 thousand and twenty-four
yesterday a hundred and fifty-seven
thousand one hundred and forty nine
people have tested positive that's an
increase of four thousand three hundred
and ten cases since yesterday fifteen
thousand and fifty one people are
currently in hospital with coronavirus
down from fifteen thousand two hundred
and thirty nine yesterday and sadly of
those hospitalized with the virus twenty
one thousand and ninety two have now
died that's an increase of three hundred
and sixty fatalities and we must never
lose sight of the human cost of
coronavirus and the pain and the grief
that it causes and each death serves as
a reminder that we must stand firm in
our resolve sadly these deaths figures
include 82 NHS colleagues and 16
colleagues who work in social care they
dedicated their lives to caring for
others and I feel a deep personal sense
of duty that we must care for their
loved ones today I'm able to announce
that the government is setting up a Life
Assurance scheme for NHS and Social Care
frontline colleagues families of staff
who died from coronavirus in the course
of their essential frontline work will
receive a sixty thousand pound payment
of course nothing replaces the loss of a
loved one but we want what we want to do
everything that we can to support
families who are dealing with this grief
and as a government we're looking
closely at other professions that work
on the front line against coronavirus
who don't who also do not have access to
such schemes to see where this may be
required